we have so much to do tonight and even
though it's this is an hour-long show
it's insane how much
we're trying to put into one program
yeah uh as you can imagine a lot of
people want to stop by a very good
friend of the show
very very good friend of our program
wanted to stop by tonight and wish us
well but
unfortunately he's in boston filming a
movie and couldn't be here in person
we said okay that's that's too bad he
said no no it's very important
for him to make an appearance he really
wanted to do it so he suggested we do it
live over zoom so please now welcome
over zoom from boston our good friend
will ferrell
hey
hi conan um yeah i'm sorry i can't be
there in person like like you said i'm
in boston
uh i'm shooting a a secret project
uh i i really wish i could talk about it
but you know how those things go
no i will i completely understand it's
batman
i'm shooting batman okay and guess what
in this version
batman gives oral all right
it's graphic okay we'll full frontal
will it's a lot more than we need to
know okay batman like you've never seen
him
all right okay okay well anyway i'm
happy for you
listen um i wanted to wish you all the
best
uh as you end an incredible run on conan
and i
i'm truly excited to see what comes next
well
god thank you will you've always been
such an amazing friend
to my show yes about that um you know i
was there for your final
late night show and your last uh tonight
show
episode and now this one yeah that's
true it's kind of become a tradition
i'll tell you what it is it's [ __ ]
exhausting
okay i mean i love you friend but but
i mean if you don't mind could i just
pre-tape a few goodbyes
and uh and you can just use them
whenever you know your next several
shows flame out
you know just have a lot no i i get yeah
sure i i guess thank
uh yeah go that's cool thank you yeah we
could just
we can just get it out of the way yeah
okay would you like me to slate
yeah that'd be great sure yeah uh this
is
will ferrell a string of conan uh talk
show goodbyes
hey conan congratulations on an
outstanding run on your hbo max show
some people will say six episodes isn't
a lot but you packed enough
entertainment
in them for eight episodes
that's great it's it's me will
uh i'm on the set of my batman sequel
and i just wanted to say
we all deeply miss your late night talk
show on
al jazeera network
conan o'brien sorry to hear about the
fatwood buddy
thank you thank you very much uh hold on
oh there's more
when i heard mtv3 was looking for a host
of their new reality show
videos of people dry humping in trucks
were the first name that popped into my
head
here we are 12 seasons later one run
i don't know how the next host will uh
be able to fill your shoes uh
but good luck logan paul jr
okay uh are you are are you are you
about done now will that's about it
right oh oh i wish we were
taken i am truly going to miss your
delta in flight talk show
wheels up
from atlanta to tampa that's great well
thank you very much
hey there conan uh youtube won't be the
same without your classic
unboxing videos
reverence and whip to such episodes as
kitchen age
serrated bread knife
yes 8 300 vgx
well okay uh will very much thanks
that's probably enough
just a couple more to be safe
conan i i thought your reality
competition show
celebrity room temperature oyster
eating contest
but then your show was tragically cut
down and it's primed by an explosive
diarrhea outbreak
who could have predicted it everyone
apparently
uh conan i've seen the footage it was
horrifying variety
called it sunday muddy sun
because instead of blood it was diarrhea
diarrhea
yeah it was still deadly yeah a lot of
people died uh-huh
not just from dysentery kim jong drown
okay
in a river of diarrhea
they had to shut down that whole sound
stage forever
it's just a big pile of deodorizing sand
now
yeah all right all right yo thank you
will that was fantastic
i'm not done shut up
finally congratulations on
filling joy behar's chair on the view
i'm sorry the show ended again because
of explosive
diarrhea okay
will uh that was very emotional thank
thank you very much that was a very
emotional series of send-offs thank you
sir the long
and windy
we don't have the money to pay for that
i know no
that wait the minute you started to sing
that i knew we couldn't afford it yeah
yeah
there you go thank you very much will
thank you and god bless you for all
you've done for us over the years you're
a great man
i'll see you at the premiere for batman
[Laughter]
hey one more time